foreign
[Music]
wow okay let me just say it is an honor
to finally meet you Sonic is it okay if
I call you Sonic everyone calls me Tails
if you're probably wondering why let me
guess because of the extra tail that's
right I should have known you'd get that
cool also what is going on robotnik's
back and who is Clifford The Big Red
Rage monster that's Knuckles the last of
the echidnas and the most dangerous
warrior in the Galaxy he's obsessed with
finding the Master Emerald are you
serious the Master Emerald that's just a
bedtime story well he believes it's real
and he must think you're the key to
finding it
yo hey where are you move your foot
[Applause]
I think we lost him
[Music]
we did not lose him we definitely did
not lose him
foreign
do you trust me of course not I
literally just met you what are you
doing
[Applause]
[Music]
we're flying uh did your butt just turn
into a helicopter
a bloodcopter oh only Sonic the Hedgehog
could come up with something like that